[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con con el
talibán controlando ahora afganistán se
declara el estado islámico esto conlleva
a una aplicación radical y extrema de la
sharía la ley religiosa que una vez más
será usada como una herramienta de
opresión contra las mujeres y también
contra las niñas las que crecieron en
afganistán en los últimos 20 años
sobrevivieron al extremismo y avanzaron
en derechos y libertades para conversar
del tema está con nosotros pilar requena
directora del programa 'documentos tv'
de la televisión española autora del
libro afganistán y la potencia reticente
y la coautora de queremos saber pilar
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
francés 24 la onu informó en julio
siendo subió en ti 1 la ofensiva de los
extremistas aumentó las muertes en
civiles en casi un 50% con más mujeres y
niños muertos y heridos en afganistán
que los primeros seis meses de cualquier
año desde que comenzaron los registros
en el año 2009 seguirán los asesinatos
selectivos con la victoria del talibán
son las mujeres afganas un botín de
guerra
vamos a ver no sólo van a seguir yo
estoy convencida los asesinatos
selectivos sino que sobre todo es
fundamental
todas las mujeres sanas van a volver a
el silencio y en la oscuridad de debajo
del burka y por supuesto la ley islámica
de la que ellos hablan que será su
interpretación de la sharía y será la
más radical y la que ya conocemos que
implantaron entre 1996 y 2001 tenemos
que tener en cuenta además que ahora hay
un nuevo fenómeno que no se produjo en
la anterior en el anterior régimen
talibán que es el secuestrar violar y
convertirla en esclavas sexuales a
través de lo que ellos llaman
matrimonios forzados de las jóvenes y de
las viudas afganas este es un fenómeno
que en principio no se dio en la última
ocasión con lo cual estamos viendo que
en 90 bulcke ahora mismo están
ofreciendo como una imagen como un
espejismo
propagandístico pero sí que llegan
informaciones de diferentes zonas donde
están cometiéndose esas prácticas
como también usted lo había dicho volvió
la burka obligatoria el cuerpo de la
mujer es de nuevo concebido como un
objeto de pecado y controlado por la
población masculina bajo la sharia pero
más allá del código de vestimenta
hablemos de la gravedad de volver a una
interpretación extrema talibán y
sinónimo de abuso matrimonio forzado
esclavización de niñas y mujeres eso le
pregunto
pero también es sobre el sobre todo es
fundamental lo que he dicho desaparece
la mujer del espacio público es decir no
pueden estudiar no pueden trabajar no
pueden ni siquiera reír si su risa es
escuchada tienen que tener todas las
presiones y todas las cocinas bajadas en
casa porque no pueden ser vistas en
ningún momento que no pueden salir de
cárcel salvo que sean acompañadas por un
por alguien de su familia directo
hombre hermano padre e hijo es decir son
condenadas a la desaparición del espacio
público luego además están ya las
prácticas aberrantes que habéis como
habéis comentado pero sobre todo hace
sobre la desaparición de la mujer del
espacio público
la cosifican para ellos la mujer es una
cosa es una cosificación
entonces si estamos hablando de que
podemos de que podemos ir a una
situación incluso peor de la que ya se
vivió en los años 90 a pesar como digo
de que ahora
con buenas palabras e imágenes
propagandísticas pero yo creo que esto
va sector de un día a madrugar lo que la
comunidad internacional todavía está
allí y hasta que se realice el final de
la evacuación si es que eso le iba a
comentar pilar porque el talibán se ha
mostrado muy abierto incluso dijo que
quería que las mujeres participaran en
su nuevo gobierno que tan fachada puede
ser esto ante la comunidad internacional
y qué tan real va a ser la participación
de respeto en las mujeres
vamos a ver yo creo que en estos 20 años
han aprendido dos cosas fundamentales
una es la diplomacia que es la que han
utilizado en doha ha cometido el error
por ejemplo eeuu de convertirlos en
carta de identidad de darles el rol de
un actor ian y han quedado cuerdos ya
con rusia y con china cosa que no pasaba
que no pasó en el año 96 y otros el
caníbal que está sobre el terreno el
bien aprendido lo que digo diplomacia se
han aprendido también propaganda y
publicidad y eso es lo que están
poniendo en estos momentos en marcha
durante estos días pero sobre todo
porque también quieren garantizarse una
cierta ayuda y quieren garantizarse sois
quedarse con ciertos puntos pilar
lamentable y terrible el escenario que
se vive entonces en afganistán en cuanto
a las mujeres gracias por su tiempo y
por estar con nosotras en france 24
volvemos con más
[Música]